(audience cheering and applauding)
- [Kelly] They're excited.
- [Dwayne] Yeah.
- [Kelly] They're very excited.
- Look at this.
- Yes.
- Look at this group.
- When you-
- I love you, I love you, too.
- When you- (laughing)
(Dwayne laughing)
When you go to, like,
Target, does that happen?
Do people just start cheering
everywhere you go? (laughing)
- Well, that's why I don't
go to Target, unfortunately.
- Oh, my God, you're missing out.
- [Dwayne] I know, dude, I know.
- It's like one of my favorite places.
- I used to love going
to Walmart at midnight.
- [Kelly] yeah, me too.
- Until I just couldn't do it anymore.
- Yeah, I was gonna say, you
can't really go incognito.
- I used to try and hide.
Right, but it used to be-
- Really?
- Well, I'd wear like
a fisherman's hat low,
and they used to be like,
"Is that the Rock with a dumb hat?"
And I would be trying to hide but-
- I feel like you can't hide.
- I cannot hide.
- Yeah.
- That went out the window.
- Yeah, I was just like
"Wow, that's amazing.
Do you just get that everywhere you go?"
That's amazing.
- Yeah, I demand it, by the way.
- I was like, "Have your people scream."
No, so you love Loretta Lynn,
did you love her growing up?
- I love Loretta Lynn.
- [Kelly] Me too.
- I really did.
And I loved her growing up.
And I grew up on country music,
traditional country music like
"Three Chords & the Truth,"
twin fiddle steel guitar kinda country.
- Yes, that's my favorite.
- Me too.
- Yeah.
- And so I lived in
Nashville a couple of times
and as a matter of fact,
I think we might have talked about this.
You guys will find this surprising.
At one time when I was 15
and hanging out in Nashville,
hanging out in bars which I
shouldn't have been doing,
but I was already like
6'4", 220 with a mustache.
I had a dream that,
my dream was I was gonna
be a country singer.
- Oh, we had this talk.
- Yeah, and that was my dream.
So what I used to do is, and
I had no money at that time,
that's where all the country bars are at,
and they're all like
dive bars as you know.
- [Kelly] Yeah, love.
- And I would kind of
like walk the streets
and be like-
♪ I kicked the habit smoking back ♪
Hoping that someone-
- Someone would be like, "Oh, hark."
- Someone will be like,
"Oh, what do you do?
You should come and sing."
(Kelly laughing)
But then, didn't happen for me.
But I love Loretta.
I love country.
- Yeah.
- Thank you for singing that with me.
- Oh my God, I was so excited.
(audience clapping and cheering)
We literally, like, ran
upstairs like yesterday
and I was like, "We
gotta make this happen."
I love this song.
I love her.
There were so many songs
you could pick from.
- [Dwayne] So many.
- But speaking of country music,
so I hear you recently went back to
the trailer park that you
used to live in, like,
when you were a teenager.
Was that, is it, I kind of like
going back to my beginnings
'cause it's like it keeps it like fresh,
that reminder of like, man,
"I had a big dream and
it worked," you know?
- Yeah.
- It was real special for me.
So two things.
When I was 15 we were,
well, we were evicted off
the island in Hawaii.
We couldn't pay rent so we were evicted.
I got sent to Nashville
to live with my Dad.
Plans change, as they do.
And I was then sent to live
with a guy who I didn't know
in a little motel room in Nashville.
- That doesn't sound shady at all.
- No, it sucked.
- Yeah.
- But, you gotta do what, you gotta do,
what you're told to do, at least at 15.
So his name was Bruno, Downtown Bruno.
Then when I broke into pro wrestling,
before I got to the WWE,
I had to hit the road like
I'm sure with you too as well.
Where before that I wrestled
in a small promotion
where we were wrestling
at flea markets and-
- Yeah.
- Used car dealerships.
You do what you gotta do.
- My first time I ever sang professionally
was at a wrestling match.
It was the national anthem.
- Oh wow, see?
- I had no idea what I was walking into
and I wore a really fancy black dress.
And I was like, "This was wrong.
I shouldn't have done this."
- This was wrong, but the voice was right.
- It was fine.
(laughter)
I was very nervous.
But it was, like, low key, not like WWE.
It was like-
- No, no.
- Yes, I mean, again, flea markets
and state fairs is where I started.
So then I went back and, again,
didn't have a place to live
'cause I didn't have any money.
And this guy, Bruno put me in his place
and he had a little trailer.
So I recently went back
after all these years
with Bruno and I went
back to this trailer,
this trailer park, actually
in Walls, Mississippi.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And it was a really moving moment
'cause it's like all that
stuff comes back to you
where it was struggle
and it was uncertainty
and what's gonna happen
and is this my life?
- [Kelly] Do you think that
that drives you though?
I feel like it drove,
it drove me to, like,
kind of break out and do something bigger,
I knew that I was capable of.
- [Dwayne] Yes.
- I feel like that
struggle kind of helped.
- Yes, Kelly, 100%.
- Yeah.
- And I, like you, I'm
sure like a lot of us,
like, I keep that right here
in the forefront of my mind.
- Amen.
- Like, I don't forget that,
and that drives me.
'Cause to me I'm-
- Makes you appreciative.
- Yeah, and so grateful
Because it can all go away like that.
So stay grounded and stay humble.
- Yeah.
I'm glad you got that experience.
That's cool.
- [Dwayne] It was amazing.
- Yeah.
- By the way, that trailer,
that little trailer
has not changed one bit.
It's the exact same trailer.
- Oh wow.
- Small, kind of like-
- It's like walking into your past.
That's crazy.
- It was unbelievable, yeah.
- So I never asked you,
but I hope you like the
socially distanced parade
that we did in your honor.
We had a one man band.
We had a juggler, even a horse,
but we did a shot of your tequila.
It was incredibly good.
- [Dwayne] Thank you.
- It went down very smooth,
but also stayed with me.
- You did a big one.
That was a thing.
- I did, I'm Texan.
So wait, so now you have this limited
Black Adam Edition of your
Zoa Energy drink, right?
- I do, yes.
- I'm afraid to try it, but I want to.
- [Dwayne] You're gonna have
to 'cause it's really good.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- And we've,
I'm very fortunate and thank you
all of you guys out there who've tried it.
We've broken all sales records.
- What?
- Yes.
- You keep doing this!
(audience cheering and applauding)
- Thank you.
- Every time I talk to you.
- It was crazy, yeah.
So, biggest launch, biggest new brand.
It was really good.
Our formulation is really, really good.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- And underscored with some
high quality science and health.
So, it's a limited Black Adam Edition.
Very cool can.
- Yeah.
- I have one, you have one.
And if you guys look under your seat
all you guys have one too.
- Where's mine?
Oh, thank you, Marcel.
- Yes
- Thank you.
- Thank you, man.
Oh, it's got electrolytes.
I'm gonna drink this after
I get my infrared sauna.
(Dwayne chuckling)
- [Dwayne] We'll do a toast.
- I love, okay, cool.
Oh it smells good.
- To Loretta.
- Oh, it's tropical punch, to Loretta!
- To Loretta, to Loretta!
- Oh see that's dangerously good.
- [Dwayne] It's very good.
- Yeah.
Ooh, I like it.
Okay, okay.
Wait, I'm gonna keep mine here
'cause you're not using this.
Okay, so do you ever mix your
energy drink with tequila?
Just asking for a friend.
- Yes.
- That might try it.
- It's so good.
You tell your friend, it mixes amazing.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- We have all kinds of flavors of Zoa,
with the tequila-
- [Kelly] Okay.
- It's perfect.
Tell your friend.
- Well, I have a dinner tonight.
I might try it with my friend.
So wait, it was a long journey
getting Black Adam made, right?
- [Dwayne] Yes.
- I feel like I had talked to a lot
of people that have these passion projects
and they take years to
actually come to fruition.
- Yes.
- [Kelly] Like, is that
like hard to, like, wait?
- Yeah, absolutely.
Especially something you want so badly
and you're so passionate about.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Black Adam has been with
me for over 10 years now.
- [Kelly] I heard, wow.
- It took a long time to get made,
and because I always felt like,
"Wait, it feels like this
is a great character,
a great anti-hero that a lot of people
can see themselves in."
- Yeah.
- But from a studio perspective,
and, you know, you've dealt with studios,
is you know, they, it's Batman, Superman,
it is Wonder Woman, and that's the go-to.
But I felt like, "Well, it feels like
we could shake up the comic book world,
the superhero genre.
Introduce new blood, new characters."
Black Adam, the Justice Society of America
is introduced in our movie.
And as a matter of fact, the JSA, right?
- Yes.
- The JSA.
Predated the Justice League.
So the JSA was the very
first superhero group, so-
- I know.
So I Googled-
- Yes.
- And after watching the
movie, I was like, "Hold up."
And I Googled, and like from 1940-
- [Dwayne] Yes.
- Is when a lot
of these characters
like Doctor Fate, like,
a lot of these characters were introduced.
And it wasn't until like
the 60s until others-
- Yes.
- Like, with the other
superheroes and I thought that was crazy.
- So many of today's famous superheroes
have gone through the JSA.
- Yeah.
- It's just a matter of
helping our partners-
- Yeah.
- See a bigger vision here.
- With Black Adam and
these other characters, so-
- [Kelly] It's brilliant, I love it.
- Thank you for watching it by the way.
- I begged for it.
Because, literally, I was like,
"Am I gonna get to screen
this before I interview them?"
I was, like, so excited.
So I loved though,
I was telling you when we were rehearsing,
I loved how it's, like, dark,
but has a really great story,
but also has this certain level of humor
that's very cool and unique to your cast.
- Yes.
- Your chemistry is amazing.
Like, whoever did all the casting.
- Yes.
- It's like this odd bunch of people
that I just never thought
I'd see in a film.
And I was like, "This works so well."
- It's a diverse group
that comes together.
We got great chemistry,
when you guys see the movie.
And we wanted to balance,
the tricky thing I think with
Black Adam is he's darker,
he's more intense, he's an
anti-hero, he's full of rage.
He was a slave 5,000 years ago.
His family was enslaved.
- [Kelly] Mm-hmm.
- His family was wiped away.
And that's his drive and his rage.
And what I always found
cool is Black Adam has
all the superpowers of Superman.
- But, like, more.
- Well, Superman's greatest weakness
is magic and kryptonite,
and Black Adam's, one of
his superpowers is magic.
So-
- Boom, boom, mic drop!
(Dwayne laughing)
- [Dwayne] Boom boom!
- Boom boom!
It's so good, it's so good.
You're always very proud
of both of your cultures
which I think is so important.
Can you talk a little bit about that?
- Yeah.
- I don't know much
about the Samoan culture,
so I think it's cool
that you teach people.
- Yeah, absolutely.
I'm half black and half Samoan.
And recently on the Samoan side,
I was, well just raised, I
was raised mainly in Hawaii
and throughout the islands.
And there's a term that we have in
the islands called "mana"
which is like spirit and power.
It like grounds us.
That you could feel now between
us, ancestors, et cetera.
So every time I go back to Hawaii,
it's always very special
just to spend time there,
spend time at the ocean.
I love taking our little girls there.
- Yeah.
- And getting that mana
seeped in their blood
so to speak, you know?
- Is it like a spiritual
energy kind of thing?
- It is, so, it's like a
mana, like, you could feel it.
It's kinda like when we come out,
the mana is real in this
room and it's very positive.
- Yeah.
- You know?
And it can vibrate in a great way, so-
- And when someone comes
in with some negative mana-
- You can feel it.
- You're like "Um, bye!"
- Yeah. (laughing)
You can feel it, yeah.
So it's a very powerful thing.
And, yeah, so every time we go back
it's always great to
introduce our daughters
to their cultures.
- Yeah.
- They are, let's see, our
daughters are part black,
part Samoan, part Armenian, part Italian.
So there's a lot going on
with our daughters, yeah.
- Yeah-
- That's a rad melting pot, though.
- [Dwayne] It's great.
- Yeah.